hello everyone and thank you all for
your insightful comments in the previous
video about the sound being too low I
raised it somewhat for this video so
hopefully you won't have to go all out
in raising your volume on your device
that you're using to watch the video now
it's a game from the final round of the
cote d'ivoire
rapid tournament in Abidjan we face is
Magnus Coulson and so far Coulson is
having an excellent tournament like the
perhaps three previous tournaments and
in the under third day he defeated
Egyptian grandmaster Bassam Amin and
Rogen's Dean Liron and now he has an
opportunity to be the first player in
chess history to break 2900 rating in
rapid chess before the tournament even
started they said that he needed a seven
and a half out of nine which is
basically six wins and three draws and
to achieve this he needs to beat wayy
with the black pieces so without further
ado let's check out the game it's really
really a crazy game not really not
really sure what to say about it more
than that I do hope you enjoy it
like we said we he has the white pieces
and he opens with E 4 we have c5 Knight
to f3 Knight to c6 and here he is not
interested to test cross and sveshnikov
so we have c3 the out pin variation with
Queen to a5 by Carlsen
if d4 comes then of course there will be
this pin and we have nice to a3
preparing Knight to c4 to kick away the
Queen we have e 6 let me just check if
I've lowered the volume of the pieces
since I don't remember so you don't have
to worry about that yeah I think I think
it's fine we have e 6 and mount nice to
see 4s play and kicking the Queen away
and then there are 23 games in the
database with this exact same position
and in all 23 Queen to c7 was played
here at Carlsen goes Queen to d8 it's a
new move and already amazing with from
move 6 we have a completely new game
it's ok with d4 as planned there's this
pin no longer exists and now that cross
and Queen supports the deep point from
the d8 square cross and also advances
the pawn all the way we have D 5 e
captures pawn captures and now Knight
CTE 5 and here of course the cross and
just continuous development and Bishop
d6 with Bishop to e3 way he does
same and now c4 with b3 the standard
idea when your opponent advanced the
point like this you want to attack it
with your flank pawn we have C captures
pawn captures and mount Knight G to e7
preparing to develop the light square
Bishop to f5 and well it's it's a nice
setup for black Bishop to d3 Bishop to
a5 s planned both players castle and
here we have Bishop to f4 increasing the
activity of this Bishop and if we look
at the position now it's a pretty equal
ish position but a white always will be
better here as not only does he have
more control in the center he also has a
semi-open file for his rook
so Crossing decides for Bishop captures
on e5 with Knight captures on e5 Knight
captures on e5 and now Bishop captures
on f5 and here now you have to decide do
you want to move the knight or do you
want to capture this Bishop if Bishop if
Knight captures Bishop then D captures
on e5 and well you could try D for to
get rid of your isolated pawn but it
doesn't work because Queen d3 attacks
the night once the knight is defended
and now you just kick it away g4 and you
will win back we're not back we just win
the d4 pawn and of course white will be
better here up upon in in a bishop
against the night game so after Bishop
captures an a5 Carson goes Knight back
to g6 and now Bishop to g5 pinning the
night not allowing to capture on f7 and
here across and goes Queen to c7 forces
a trade because now the bishop on f5 is
still under attack and also the Queen is
attacking the c3 pawn which is the weak
point it's a backwards pawn once you get
rid of it then the b3 point is also weak
so we don't want to allow this way ego's
Bishop captures on g6 with Knight
captures and g6 and now just Queen to f3
defending the c3 pawn but also putting
pressure on the d5 pawn we have Queen to
d7 saying okay
for the moment I will defend this and
then now comes rook to a5 attacking the
pawn here and now there are a few ways
you could deal with this now you could
defend it by going something like f6
kick the bishop away and then go 97 were
denied an Queen or together defend the
d5 pawn or you could play what call some
played b5
it prevents the rook from now attacking
the d5 pawn but and makes it very
inactive but it also allows this rook
after a one move which really takes
control of the a file so it will be very
hard to keep defending on the Queen side
we have h6 by cross and Russia back to
d2 and now comes Luke f28 taking the the
open e file as a way you decided to take
the the semi open a file we have Queen
to d3 now with a double attack against
the b5 point and here Carlson defends it
would with a very nice tactic Colson
finds a six and it's a it's a really
cool line because it basically gives a
pawn but you will get so much activity
for it well you'll just have to see what
happens way he captures it we have route
captures on a6 rook captures and a6 rook
captures on a6 and now of course Knight
to f4 which is a really a powerful move
already you can see that ideas like
Queen g4 Queen g2 are coming in 92 Czech
becomes possible and the Queen is under
attack Bishop of course cannot capture
due to this rook e1 where you would lose
the Queen and it's just just a very nice
position for black so giving up a pawn
but gaining a lot of activity we have
Queen to f3 by wayyy and now Queen to f5
again a wonderful move our where the
night is still off-limits
if Queen captures then just Queen B 1
check Russia blocks a rocky one again
will be checkmate
so after this Queen to a5 more we have
rook to a 1 we see that he does have to
defended the week back rank and now
comes night Stewie to check King to F 1
and now Queen to c2 and this is where
the where the fun starts
as we he has to decide how to deal with
this there's no good way to defend the
bishop on d2 if you go Bishop e3 then
you start losing pawns on the Queen side
but even though it's not all that
favorable for white it is well it is
probably not win c3
about the Knight captures on c3 you
don't want to hang the night but it is
the the best line of defense for white
for example g3 make some room for your
king you
lose yet another porn on the queenside
but at least you you can start playing
the game once again now let's say 94
white will threaten checkmate here with
Queen f7 Queen g7 Knight f6 black has to
go back a little bit and our way you
will have to figure out how to deal with
the past B point but wayy isn't
interested in playing well a slightly
worse position against world champion so
he decides for Queen captures I need to
he gives up the queen for a night and
the rook and says I will try to create a
fortress and as well everyone knows
magnus carlsen doesn't believe in
fortresses he says okay challenge
accepted
we have rook captures any - King
captures any - and now you could grab
the b3 point immediately first cross
some tests wait to see what's going on
whether he will defend the g2 pawn or
not he does with king of one and now
cross and repeats we have King back to
e2 Queen captures on b3 and now comes
Luke the c1 just defending the c3 pawn
once again and saying okay you have a
queen but I have a bishop and the rook
plus you know five points each I can
hold this so let's see what happens
Carson goes Quincy four check with King
III and the now comes Quinta Queen to c7
going after the h2 upon F for blocking
and now Queen to e7 check King to f2 and
now comes the Queen to e4 so the black
queen gets the most active square on the
board that is d4 square and now white
just has to you know keep everything
intact and not allow Carson to make any
progress we have rook to e1 Queen to d3
and not look to e to
everything is defended from from White's
perspective and you have to really
decide what to do here you could go for
something like b4 saying okay you grab
that pawn then I'll grab this point but
after C captures in Queen captures and
d4 with Czech Bishop to e3 you could
grab this one but it's it's gonna be a
bit harder to get this pawn rolling all
the way so crossing decides for a
different plan first he wants to get his
King into the game and he wants to
improve the pawn structure on the under
King side with f6 making room for the
King to enter the game King g1
course why just repeats king of seven
with rook to e3 queen bee one check King
to f2 and now comes h5 with h3 by ye h4
by Carlsen limiting the mobility of way
these pieces and King Bishop to e1 and
now just came to g6 now we have rook to
f3 with maybe ideas of pushing f5 and
then maybe some Bishop to d2 can create
some tricks against Carson's king but
just came to a5 blocking the pawn and
again increasing the activity of course
and scheme we have king e to Queen to f4
check King back to f1 and now finally
that now everything is well the position
of cross and King has increased we have
b4 as plan now the d4 pawn will become
weak C capture son before we have Queen
captures on d4 and now Bishop captures
on h4 so we grabs another pawn but
Quinta c4 checked with King to g1 and
now Queen captures and before so this is
the lion cross and preferred to the one
that we've shown that also creates a
pass D pawn but now he has a more active
King and well way these pieces aren't
all in front of the the past D pawn king
f1 we have Queen to c4 check King to g1
and now Queen to e 2 with Bishop to f2
blocking the D pawn but it doesn't
really block the deep one this is what
cousin had in mind just d4 and now you
will not be able to prevent d3 d2 and d1
so you have to capture it Bishop
captures on d4 but now Queen d1 check
King h2 and now Queen captures on d4 so
the passed pawn is no more but white
lost the bishop so now it's a queen and
two points against the rook and three
points we still trying to create some
sort of a fortress for across and not to
be able to penetrate
rook to f1 and just repeating g6 now
with rook to f3 and now we have Queen to
d2 route back to f1 by way now comes
clean to e4 with rook to f3 and here
quickly to and now this is the idea if
you're not careful let's say you try
something like team to h1 then cosine
will just play Queen captures rook you
don't need a queen anymore captures
captures king h2 and now it's a
completely winning King and pawn endgame
that well white would immediately resign
so we have looked to g3 way rather tries
to give up upon for for the g6 point but
cross and just defends that Queen to h5
saying I'm gonna win this pawn later
rogue g4 not allowing it and now King to
e3 and it was in fact in this move and
in this position unmoved sixty that we
didn't resign the game but rather he
lost on time he ran out of time but it
is a completely winning position for for
Carlson here if you try something like
well there's really nothing to try you
could go King g1 or something but then
you get f5 and rook has to go away we
could show one of the lines let's say
Kim Ji Won f5 rook to g3
let's say you try and give a check King
captures an f4 rook to a3 check King to
e4 and now rook to f1 with Queen - e -
and now you could go with a rook to f3
or you look to a3 but then we go into
the same line and captures captures
captures and then it's again a winning
King and pawn endgame but the point is
that now the rook would have to finally
move let's say Rho K 1 and now the rook
hunt begins
so now we could show a line let's say
Queen d2 hoping to get Queen d4 check in
to win the rook here
rook to f1 and now comes Queen to d4
check King to h1 Queen to c3 I'm just
trying to get hold of the of the g3
square King to g1 let's say F for now
King - h1 g5 came to g1 and now Queen to
d4 check King to h1 now comes Queen 33
King to h2 now comes King to d3 you also
want to get the King into the game let's
say it's right king h1 kingi - now the
rock is under attack rook to anyone and
now King to F - let's say rugby one
knock comes Queen to d3 attacking the
rook rook the c1 and now Quinta e4
finally you threaten checkmate you don't
allow any checks on c2 and here you
would force the rook to the block with
rook to g1 and now you just go King to
g3 and now you have the ultimate to
swanned where white has to start to
reading his position and he will soon
get checkmated
to h4 captures and now any move that
black makes with the rook ends in
checkmate let's say rook e1 this is
checkmate but any other move would also
end in checkmate so it is a completely
winning position for Carson and without
finding any solutions we try to find one
for the rest of the game and then of
course his time ran out so like we said
after this sorry sorry about that after
this King teeth remove away he was some
time and Carson was able to get seven
and a half out of nine in this
tournament and he is the first player in
chess history to break 2900 in rapid
ratings so here we have first we're
gonna show the standings of the
tournament here they are
as you can see Magnus Carlsen in first
place with 15 points followed by
Nakamura with 12 and Maxie Marshall Agra
with 11 followed by Wesley so Bingley
runway II sadly Carrick in a vessel into
Pallavi on the pony she and Bassam Amin
in last place with five points and here
I have prepared the live ratings there
you have it as you can see crossing in
classical twenty eight seventy five
point four but in rapid 2903 point O so
officially the first player in chess
history to break 2900 in rapid in blitz
already three players have 2900 Carlsen
Maxie Marshall de Graaff and I believe
Nakamura Bingley Rijn at one point I
believe also had 2900 not sure about
that but I think at one point in England
was that was the highest-rated blitz
player in the world so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and this
short coverage of determinants I'm sorry
I wasn't able to show more games as so
many cool games are being played but I'm
not at my own home so I'm really trying
to make make it possible to cover more
games but I will for the games that you
have requested like Bassam Amin vs.
Nakamura I will show it when I return to
my hometown so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Brice Foster Michael Keller Robert
Kretchmer Ralph Rix and tarish carpi up
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the this
cote d'ivoire
blitz tournament that was going on today
tomorrow and you know checking a company
or suggestions when this finishes were
returning to the capo Blanca saga and so
on and so on thank y'all I will see you
soon have an excellent rest of your
Saturday